you really need to focus on the
positives and and you really need to
accept your situation as well because
what I see in a lot of my clients is
that they're really loved complaining
and they're really loved blaming the
circumstances for what's happening to
them if you won't take action nothing
will happen and this is what should
motivate you Elena how are you yes I'm
very good thank you how are you very
good pleasure to have you here so what
are we what are we gonna be talking
about today okay so today I think we're
going to be emphasizing the importance
of self-improvement and basically
growing your confidence in order to
achieve better results in both
intrapreneurship and personal life
because what happens is that like I see
this very often in my work is that
people with low self-esteem like just
get caught up in negative feedback loops
of inaction and failure and as a result
they can't achieve the result that they
want what is your job okay so I have I
do have an interdisciplinary background
and I basically I I started studying
psychology so my major was in psychology
then I opened up my first consulting
business which was a successful business
for five years and it grew to a Wellness
Center I then pursued my master's degree
in the neuroscience and genetics and I
fell in love with science so I
co-founded a biotech startup after this
and eventually I ended up doing a PhD in
stem cell biology and at the moment I'm
on my final year writing my thesis and I
just launched my third business which is
the guild of growth and I offer
one-on-one mentorship for new and
aspiring entrepreneurs on business
strategy mindset of success and
confidence growth Wow that is you are a
busy woman you're a very busy woman
yes I'm indeed so okay we're talking
about confidence how that relates how
self-esteem relates to people's success
both
and personally what are some of the
common challenges that you see when
you're working with your clients so
first of all what happens is that when
what your self-esteem is low usually you
can't even start taking action because
of your subconscious blocks and the fact
that you think that you're not actually
worthy of taking action and improving
your situation and you know going after
the goals that you really want so it all
starts with the feeling of self-worth
and the fact that most of people don't
actually feel that they're worthy of
positive changes in their lives and the
reason behind this is that they actually
are not doing anything extraordinary
anything good in order to prove to
themselves and their subconscious mind
that they are worthy of a positive
change you know so it all starts with
inaction and I keep on seeing this again
and again and I i recently tweeted
something along lines that 9 out of 10
people around you they are actually
they're just doing their bare minimum ok
so the competition is very very low the
bar is set very very low right now and
it's crazy because like we live in such
an amazing era where like the whole
planet is connected online and you have
access to infinite free resources online
in order you know to to get out there
and become financially independent and
you know that become
the-best-version-of-yourself
you know you want to lose weight there
is a bunch of tutorials online you know
you want to make money there is like
hundreds of you know ways to make money
online nowadays you just need to
actually decide that you want to take
action and then you need to just
basically start and most people don't
even start and it really hurts me you
know this is the reason why I started
the guild of growth because I've been so
right now as I said I'm on my first year
of PhD and so I've been in an academic
environment for the past like three and
a half years and you know we've been
talking with
and you know colleagues in academia that
have great business ideas but they have
no idea where to start and they kept on
asking me different kind of things they
kept on asking me like different tips
how to start where to find the resources
to start how to you know like take a
business off the ground
and you know they literally kept telling
me Elena okay you should start a podcast
or you should start a Facebook group or
something and then I realize that yes
like I do need to kind of you know put
some put this knowledge out there
because like through both my first
business which was running for five
years and my biotech startup I learned
this this process of basically imperfect
massive action and that if you won't
start if you won't take action today
nothing will happen you know and it's
just so simple and you've probably heard
this before but you know not not many
implemented what surprises me is seeing
people so you're talking about some of
the other academics that you spend your
time with these people are so competent
they've got so many talents I'm around
tons and tons of people who I look at
I'm oh my god like you're so well
educated wise in a particular discipline
have this this this this and this but
you're totally correct if you multiply
by 0 and that 0 is no action then yeah
everything that came before hits a very
very hard brick wall and I love I love
the idea that 9 out of 10 people are
doing the bare minimum to get by
therefore the bar is set very low I
think you're sadly I think that you're
very right I can't speak for other
countries but certainly in the UK there
is a lack of agency of upward mobility
of people's desire to become sovereign
individuals you know and just do their
thing and this doesn't matter this isn't
me sane like everybody should become an
entrepreneur like this isn't me saying
that it's just me it's just me saying
that you can take control of your own
growth either personally or
professionally financially fitness-wise
whatever it might be you are in control
and yeah
I think if you're on a couple of really
interesting points there so you
mentioned that you had a process a
framework a plan can you take us through
that yeah yeah sure can I just comment
on what you just said first because I
think I have a couple of more
interesting points there so you're
absolutely right and I think that this
frame of mind as is prevalent in most
countries today really and the other
thing is that the academics so people
that have you know have been through an
undergrad degree and then they proceed
with a master's degree in a PhD they're
all very very smart but what happens is
that they don't really have this
real-life experience outside academia so
they're really focused on their science
and truth is that research demands you
to be a really really committed and
spend a lot of hours in the lab or you
know doing your literature review things
like this so they're actually don't
really know that there is this this
amazing world out there and you know our
world is rapidly change it's changing
and it has like it's changed
dramatically over the past decade you
know like 15 years ago there was no
YouTube so there were no resources and
like it all starts at a young age so for
instance our parents like they don't
even understand the concept of making
money online you know and it all starts
with school as well because they don't
teach us you know like financial
literacy literacy basically at school so
like most of people don't even think
about it because no one told them like
what to think about they don't know what
they don't know you never know you can't
know what you don't know that's a very
good point
I wonder how much of a difference the
children of re run now so someone who is
you know between Norton ten in 2020 I
wonder how much different their view
professionally and personally of the
world and how much of a growth mindset
and stuff they will have because I
certainly feel like Millennials which is
technically 84 to 96 I think they were
part of
a corner turn that's such an inflection
point that totally detached their
experience from their parents yeah that
it could happen again there could be
another huge wave of change coming but
something tells me that there probably
won't that I'll probably be able to have
more in common with my children's life
experiences than my parents do with mine
do you what do you think about that yeah
yeah absolutely because thing is that
the turning point for our generation for
the millennial generation was basically
the Internet and the fact that you know
like the whole way of living like half
of our of our like time that we spend a
week is probably online now you know and
especially in the few of the recent
events everyone like there is like a
vast majority of people that is working
online now in their transition in online
and there will be a bunch of people that
you know will be working on their side
hustles and their online incomes right
now while being at their 95 so they will
probably they won't have this desire to
actually go back to their 95 and I think
that like what internet really brings is
the decentralization of of
professionalism and you know like we're
we're getting into this gig economy and
I think that it's here to stay and you
know everyone will be their own boss or
the vast majority of people will keep on
being their own boss in the future and I
think this is what will be what will be
present in the next generation as well
yeah I think so David Parral one of my
favorite bloggers past modern wisdom
guests has this thing where he says
you're sad hustle has a side hustle
which is this this like multivariate
stream of income world that some people
have ventured into and right now you are
seeing those that did have multiple
streams of income perhaps an income from
property perhaps something that was more
web based perhaps some investments and
other bits and pieces they're the ones
who have the most robust financial
makeups and perhaps even an anti fragile
makeup if they've been particularly
clever and had
or say and some people might be making
more money right now I know it has shown
of people that are making more money on
their internet businesses because
everyone's spending like screen times
probably gone up by like a hundred
percent which is crazy so let's get on
to your framework we've got people that
are listening they think yeah this
sounds great I'd like to become a
sovereign individual with high agency
and a bunch of other stuff but in action
imposter syndrome I don't know where to
start where do we even begin yeah okay
so the first step is to recognize that
the current system of action that you
have in place does not produce the
results that you want okay so once you
realize this and once you understand
that with your current actions your
trajectory is not taking you where
you're want to go okay so this is the
first step and the second step would be
to define a clear plan of action and
actually ask yourself because like again
like what happens today is that
everything is go global okay so like
ninety-eight percent of the information
that you need in order to become
successful is out there okay maybe it's
even a hundred percent like for most
people it's a hundred percent okay like
you need to dig a bit but you know I'm
sure that you'll be able to find the
information that you actually need in
order to start something and create
something from nothing and in terms of
business what happens is that there are
three core aspects that can that can all
be built on my nowadays and first you
need to know what your customers want
and like the mistake that most
individuals do is that they start
working on an idea that they think is
really great and it actually solves a
solution it solves a problem that that
people have and it provides a particular
solution but what happens is that
they're not really validating it and
nowadays again with the social media you
can get so much validation for your idea
you know you just send out a bunch of
questionnaires out there and you see
what happens and you see what is you
know the the the product or the service
that can be
marketed to a thirsty market in order to
you know to copper need and solve a
problem and then what you do is you
polish this product or service and again
like now it's easier than ever to create
digital products and provide services
online things like this so once you
realize what the customer wants what the
market wants you can basically move into
creating a product or service that is
desirable and then the next step the
third step is to create a distribution
channel and again nowadays like it's
easier than able to create a
distribution channel so one example
could be a YouTube channel right that
provides very valuable content and then
you know you can you can monetize this
or social media account things like this
but in order to to go back into the the
negative feedback loop and the the
self-esteem and how to actually start
and how to decide that you are worth you
of starting you really need to focus on
the positives and and you really need to
accept your situation as well because
what I see in a lot of my clients is
that they're really loved complaining
and they're really loved blaming the
circumstances for what's happening to
them okay so in terms of the perspective
change the most important perspective
that you need to change is the
perspective of yourself and just focus
on the existing resources that you have
this might be a skill that you know
you're honing or anything that you're
passionate about and then really take it
from there and tell yourself okay so it
is what it is yes I'm unlike you know my
parents going through a divorce or you
know I'm I'm really unhappy in life now
I'm going through a breakup something
like this but if you won't take action
nothing will happen and this is what
should motivate you because once you
realize like look there are people out
there that's utilizing like all the
online resources I have access to you as
well and you know that it should click
and basically you should realize that
look it is what it is
and I just focus on taking action every
single day and then the second step is
would be to to be your own
accountability partner and I think that
this is another kind of perspective that
can only lead to positive outcomes when
you realize that you don't need to be
disciplined only when you're supervised
you know it's interesting at the moment
that we have everyone being released
from the world of work right they no
longer have their boss breathing down
their neck they no longer have the
structures that discipline them
previously and to the people who have
had to make that nomadic work from home
transition I am I feel for you because
it took me a decade to work out how to
manage myself and you've just been
expected to do it if the world stopped
everyone's that right got to work from
home now and you're like oh hang on what
time do I get up where do I work from
how do I am I supposed to get dressed
when do I have a coffee when do I go for
a break up I work too much ever work too
little you know it's it's real
challenging there's a ton of different
things that you went through that I
thought was interesting I like the idea
that your current outcomes being an
indicative of your current inputs and
then if you are not if you're not
getting the outcomes that you want you
have to presume that something is going
wrong with the inputs no you're right
there are people out there who get head
starts people who out there who get
what's the opposite of a head start
whatever that is ahead I've come a bum
start I don't know whatever that is
whatever the thing is when they go
behind it like a disadvantage there's
people that have both of those but that
can't be changed it comes back to the
stoic principle of the dichotomy of
control what can you control what can't
you control just do the things that you
can when it comes to the self-esteem and
people blaming circumstance or are the
bits and pieces is that just them being
able to point the finger at something
which isn't their self or is there
something going on here something else
going on
it's just the reason that that they
point the fingers to someone else is
that they they're not happy with
themselves and for this reason they
don't want to bear the responsibility
because they think that they're unworthy
of being responsible for their own life
okay so it all comes back to to this
feeling of unworthiness because what
they're currently doing is not producing
the results that they want so they're
they're just basically give up and this
is what separates a winner from a loser
okay so winner just keeps on going until
he wins he or she wins I'm gonna guess
that you'll be familiar with the learned
helplessness study on dogs have you
heard this word okay so this identifies
I think one of the things that you might
be getting at so it's a very famous
study done quite a while ago and dogs
were put in a cage and the floor was
shocked so it was uncomfortable for the
dogs shock the dogs in there was three
groups in the first group the dogs had a
little button that they could press and
if they press the button then it went
away in the second group the dogs had a
button that they could press and if they
press the button nothing happened so
they just kept on getting shocked and
then in the third group if they press
the button sorry they didn't get shocked
at all right so three three different
groups of dogs roll it forward second
iteration of the study they're now put
into a different cage different button
same shocks all three sets of dogs and
our shocks are
remember that the third set was never
shocked in the first place yeah first
set who had the button that worked they
go over to the button and they press it
the third set who were never shocked in
the first place they also go over to the
button and they push it but the second
group who the first time the button
didn't do anything they just curled up
on the floor and didn't try to go and
press the button despite the fact that
that button worked so what that was then
moved into was a theory of learned
helplessness and that over time if the
world continues to keep on beating you
after a while you just think no this
isn't for me I'm just gonna give up but
that's a natural response yeah it's it's
basically conditioning so when you're
conditioned to certain circumstances you
don't even try and change your
circumstances because you think that you
don't have control over them but this is
what my my message basically was is that
what can give you hope and what can give
you the willingness to try something new
to produce some results is the
realization that you're actually the
only person that is in control of their
lives and you know your situation
sometimes it's hard to change your
situation but like you can change your
perspective and you can change what
you're getting out of a situation okay
so you know we have seven people seven
billion people on the planet and you
know unfortunately most of them are
conditioned to not take action perhaps
because of their family beliefs or
perhaps of the fact that they tried
something and it didn't work but if you
and you know there is this myth of
overnight success and you know we we see
articles about successful entrepreneurs
and you know there are some misleading
titles saying that oh you know like
entrepreneur a had an overnight success
and it's never an overnight success this
is what my career taught me as well you
know I had to iterate I had to go
through a lot of like difficulties
through my career and you know it's
never straightforward and you know after
running my business so I'm originally
from Greece after running my business my
first business and
for five years I moved to the UK to do
my master's degree and you know I was a
self-funded student I wasn't working for
a year at some point my savings run out
you know I I was in a hard situation and
then after completing my masters I had
different kind of options to get a job
or do something else and then I found
this school biotech startup that was
looking for a co-founder and I knew that
I wouldn't get a salary but it was like
it was a priceless experience I learned
so much you know and you know it was
definitely worth it and you know I I was
I was telling about this experience to a
friend of mine and he said something
along the lines oh my god I let you know
you were so brave back then and you took
a leap of faith and like you didn't
think about quitting or getting a job
and I said that for me quitting was
never an option and you know maybe I
have this kind of mindset because I
basically was never an employee before
so I started my first business at 22
straight after my my bachelor's degree
and I could and the reason that I
started and I was looking for different
kinds of you know opportunities is that
like I don't know maybe it's in my blood
or something but I really love a good
challenge and I I couldn't imagine
myself being contained in a 95 Joe yeah
I get that I wonder how can someone it's
all well and good for me and you who've
been indoctrinated into this
entrepreneurial world since we were
teenagers / early twenties but you know
someone who's not from this world might
just listen to what you're saying there
I know it's all well and good for you
as you super achieve in like brain box
with five degrees and and and tech
startup and all this sort of stuff but
I'm just I'm just a normal guy or a
normal girl I don't have this
indomitable spirit I don't have that's a
really in Dom in the indomitable
whatever that word indomitable I don't
have this unbeatable spirit yeah but how
do i how do I get over it how do I get
over myself I don't think that I can do
that that's easy for you to say you know
that first step
doesn't matter what you think you need
to ask yourself okay if I start trying
what's the worst that can happen to me
you know like are you gonna die are you
gonna like you know become homeless or
something I mean if you run this risk
you probably shouldn't start your own
business but you know what I'm saying
and like I'll give you an example of my
third business basically the one that I
started a few months ago I set up the
whole business in the UK in a matter of
two days you know I found a virtual
office address I registered the company
you know I I set up a business bank
account and it all took me I don't know
less than a hundred pounds and less than
two days to organize you know creating a
business is easier than ever and
especially like with this with this
freelancing economy that we're in the
moment like you don't need to to be so
anxious about you know about organizing
the whole thing because like 20 years
ago if you wanted to start a business
you know you should have rented a place
and you know bought an inventory things
like that so now with you know with
online products and online services that
you can you can start like what's the
worst thing that can happen you know and
like I think that Tim Ferriss mentions
in his 4-hour workweek mentions that if
you're really afraid to take a leap of
faith
like literally rate your fear from 0 to
10 okay what's the worst that can happen
is it really that bad you know just put
things into perspective with zero being
like zero negative consequences and ten
being you you know like losing a limp or
something you know like what what's the
worst that can happen you know you like
you can start and you get you can start
working in a business or an idea in your
free time and then this is where time
management comes in as well because
people are also conditioned having
certain habits and you know but mind
watching Netflix and like every weekend
and then again you need to ask yourself
do I really need to do this and you
to evaluate your trajectory and ask
yourself okay if in five years from now
I want to be making seven figures if in
five years from now I want to buy a
Ferrari like why am i buying watching
netflix every weekend like it doesn't
make any sense you know like perhaps you
should prioritize your stuff a bit
better before saying that it's actually
not possible I agree I think assessing
the daily actions that you take and then
realizing what happens if you roll the
clock forward from there is empowering
and also scary it's terrifying in the
same breath right because you realize
just how many of the things you do don't
serve the end result that you actually
want Mackley one thing I've been
thinking a lot about recently has been
to do with people's trust in their own
word so a lot of the time people try and
enact some form of behavior change I'm
gonna lose weight I'm gonna stop smoking
I'm gonna get up early I'm gonna be
nicer to my partner I'm gonna stop
arguing with whatever spend time on my
phone and a lot of the time habits and
behavior changes don't go tremendously
well and people end up going back to
their old modes of operating and if you
do that enough times it's like if you
imagine being friends with someone who
always you'd say hey are we are we
meeting at the coffee shop at one
o'clock and they'd say yeah yeah we're
meeting at one o'clock and then you turn
to put one o'clock and they're not there
I mean like what happened oh yeah sorry
this thing came up and I okay okay fair
enough fair enough and then a couple of
weeks later something else
okay so we're making it three o'clock
yeah we're making it through and then
they continue to not turn up like think
about what would happen they're after
time you would lose faith in your
friends ability to ever do what they say
they're going to do and you have to
consider that you're treating yourself
like that person and this is something
that I've seen increasingly since
lockdown began because I've had fewer
distractions I've actually been able to
keep promises to myself much more
effectively which has raised my own
trust in my own word which means I can
then say bigger things to myself and
have
they'll follow through with them so
confidence brutally and empowering Lee
is a feedback loop on both sides a lack
of comments inspires further lacks of
confidence but increases in confidence
in inspire increases in confidence so
yeah this is how you go from a negative
feedback loop to a positive feedback
loop of results and then more action and
this is something really great and I I
definitely agree with you I used to have
friends that used to be late all the
time so they're not my friends anymore
dicks that's what they're called they're
not called friends I called dick Salina
and then I totally agree with you that
in isolation you can actually be more
accountable if you really can focus on
the things that matter to you and I've
been seeing the same thing with myself
you know before the lockdown
I was too inconsistent with my workouts
but now I work out every day and I'm
looking forward to it and I'm going for
for a walk around like every single day
and you know it's it's been amazing
really and this reinforces it even more
and now I can't wait to get up and
actually you know go for a run well one
thing again to consider there is if you
are thinking this sounds good I like the
idea of becoming a little bit more
motivated more confidence building more
confidence seems to make sense to me
it's compounding interest that's one of
the key that's the eighth great wonder
of the world is Warren Buffett called it
but I need to I need to overcome my
principal inertia that is that first
period is always the most uncomfortable
in behavior change because it's when
you're putting in all of the effort all
of the discomfort feeling all of the
challenge and not seeing any results and
unfortunately that is what happens so I
use this analogy this month so this is
the 20th of May when we're recording
this episode since the beginning of May
until now I've done more plays on modern
wisdom than I did in all of 2018 oh wow
20 days worth of plays more than 12
months worth of plays
so if I had the mindset that I do now
with regards to where I pitched the the
exposure for the podcast back then I'd
be like what am i doing why am i putting
out an episode a week when it's getting
you know 150 second of what I could get
in half a month you know that like why
would I be doing that but again like
there's lead measures and there's like
measures the lead measure will always be
uncomfortable you're going to be getting
up early you're going to be doing
learning things getting confused online
getting frustrated realizing that you
set the business up with the wrong
postcode and having a recenter card but
you know all of those different things
and you're like right okay that bit
sucks but if it's just single stepping
stones every mistake is just a lesson
that you don't repeat and you just
continue to chew through it you're like
I am making progress I am getting there
even if I can't see it yeah this is how
you motivate yourself by realizing that
every mistake is a stepping stone for
the next thing that you're going to be
doing right and this is like this is how
you can achieve big goals as well by
basically breaking them down in smaller
and like much more likely achievable
goals in order for you to to start
having some progress and get those
dopamine cakes that will trigger the
positive feedback loop I mean this is
what I'm I'm telling my customers as
well is that if you have a certain goal
in five years from now to be making
let's say seven figures you know this is
a very very abstract goal in your
subconscious mind probably cannot even
imagine it so what you do is you ask
yourself okay
in order for me to achieve this goal
what do I need to achieve in one year
from now and then you break this down
even further and you say okay in six
months from now where do I need to be
how many customers do I need to have in
six months from now so what does this
mean for my even more short-term goal of
a 1 month ok so in the next 30 days I
have a solid plan of action I have 4
weeks and I need to achieve goal XY and
Z and this is it and if I don't achieve
it I know that I need to move into a
different direction I know that I need
to test out different things and this is
another
very useful trade in entrepreneurship is
that when you're trying things out and
you don't work and they don't work it's
actually a good thing because you
eliminated an assumption that you had
before and now you know that there is a
different direction that you need to go
into okay so this is actually so so
valuable well I think inevitably because
of what we see of other people's conduct
we see the highlight reel you don't see
the failures or at least you don't see
them that much unless it's failure
failure / hustle porn which is quite
common I guess in Silicon Valley but yet
you don't see that so you just presume
that your failures is you being an idiot
not a normal byproduct of doing a
complex thing in a complex world yeah my
god the failure is that I face so far
and especially you know in my academic
career so when I when I completed my
master's degree and I was looking for
for PhD projects I got something like 20
rejections and some of the rejections
that I got them even before apply so I
would just contact the supervisor saying
hi this is Elena this is my CV this is
what I did so far blah blah blah
I won a wet lab project I really love
science I'm in love with molecular
biology but I have a bachelor's degree
in psychology and you know the the reply
was yeah yeah thank you for your
consideration but you don't even need to
apply yeah so true story there and then
I met my my current PhD supervisor and
he just he could just see this spark in
me and my passion about what I'm doing
which is driven by the results that I'm
seeing and the impact that I could be
happy
been into you know like patients lives
and you know really benefit as many
people as possible with my research and
you know he trusted me on this and here
we are you know I I haven't even
finished my PhD yet and I already have
like over like a hundred and ten
citations or something you know it's
it's really thank you
yeah I think this kind of ties in to
self-esteem certainly and also one of
the reasons that some people might not
like to work as hard as they could or
put themselves out there because if you
don't bother trying to do something you
always have culpable deniability that
you could have made it work but just
didn't bother whereas if you try and
fail that is a very harsh reflection on
your capacity and because people are
unable to detach their sense of self
from their sense of success yeah that is
essentially the same as the world
telling you you are not worthy not that
your business just sucked or you tried
to launch a garden center in the middle
of coronavirus or you know I mean like
does that mean perfect example there
someone tries to launch a business
they've been building a coffee shop for
the last year-and-a-half saving up money
for the last five years they've retired
away into the countryside create this
beautiful coffee shop ready to launch
March 20th ready to launch whatever it
was as March 22nd Boris comes in takes a
big sledgehammer and just smashes it
through the window and you're like okay
does that mean that you suck as a person
does that mean no it means that the
world is chaotic and messy and
unfortunately sometimes you come off on
the right side sometimes you don't
that's why lady Fortuna was back in your
country's ancient days that's why she
gave and take right it wasn't that you
were a loser it's that you were
unfortunate yeah absolutely and what
happens is that when you do see those
failures and you do connect them to your
self-esteem you actually need to realize
that world being a scary place is not
the only explanation here because maybe
the world just wants to tell you wants
to take care of you until you look
unfortunately this is not the way it's
going to work try something else
you know and then you you just keep
going and the way I see it again I
really love challenges I do understand
that this is not how many people think
some people are are not so
getting out of their comfort zone but
what they need to realize is that if
you're sitting on your couch there is a
hundred percent probability that you're
not going to make it you know like here
you're not going to build your new
business by just buying watching Netflix
Howard it's inevitable that you will not
succeed okay so like if you're really
afraid of failure like you're bringing
this into your your life well yeah
that's it's like it's like imagining
imagining the worst fear that you can
and then manifesting it at the same time
yeah if you'd spend all of your time
worrying about whether or not you're
going to make something of your short
time on this earth and decide to not
change the actions you are taking you're
assuring yourself of your own
destruction or at least assuring
yourself that your own nightmare is
going to come into reality it's just it
is is hard right because you see you see
you see the world you see your place in
the world and your capacity and how
successful you are or how good you are
as a parent a brother or a business
owner or a boss a leader whatever it
might be you see these things and you
feel like they are existential label
placed on you this is this symbolic huge
curse or blessing given from the gods
and you like I know that that's what it
feels like and trust me like I've been
through business as well I've been
through so many neurotic terrible
mindset places where I've attached my
sense of self-worth to my sense of
success and all this sort of stuff
throughout you know the last 13 years of
running businesses nearly 14 now and it
does it feels grand and esoteric and and
and like you are attached to the
universe somehow but it's just things
happening in life that's all it is
that's all that anything really is and I
hope I hope that we're drilling this
nail constantly hitting it with a
massive hammer of self esteem so that
people can realize
they are able to enact change within
their life that the things their
outcomes in their life are under their
control exactly and I think that when
you're in this dark place of a negative
feedback loop of inaction and failure
and you don't really know how to get
inspired what I find really really
inspirational and interesting is to read
a biography of a person that I really
admire okay sorry who like like Elon
Musk or Richard Branson you know you you
read their autobiographies and you're
just like it's mind-blowing how much
action did they take until the thing
started working and when you when you
see examples when you start training
your brain with examples of people that
have made it I think that your mindset
will start changing a bit and again
today it's easier than ever to do this
because you just go online and you you
can listen to audio books or listen to
podcasts or interviews of great men and
women and then you'll realize that look
there is actually a different reality
out there because what happens nowadays
is that when you're surrounded with
people that do not inspire you it makes
sense that you actually won't take
action and this is why something else
very important is to to surround
yourself with friends and people that
that have like the mindset that you you
would like to have more of okay because
when you're in an environment where no
like everyone's on their 9:00 to 5:00
and this is their world and you know
they're going to the pub every Friday
night and this is it and this is what
gives them the dopamine kick like you
should ask yourself okay so if I do the
same things that they're doing like what
what are the outcomes that I'll be
having and then you realize that wait a
minute so this is actually a compromise
and I can achieve more if I start having
different actions if I start you know
reading audio like listening to audio
books
they're going to the pub and then you
know your perspective changes and then
you realize okay so this is not
everything that's that's there out there
for me I agree and especially online you
can find communities of people now it's
not just that you have to be in the same
location you can find a reddit thread or
a whatsapp chat or a YouTube channel or
a discord server or whatever it might be
that has some people in there that make
you feel like you're speaking to them
right or like they're speaking to you
one of the things that I get messages
very very complimentary probably my
favorite type of messages that I receive
about the podcast is when people say hey
man I really enjoyed the show just wait
to let you know like sometimes I feel
like I don't have a whole lot of people
that think like me wherever I live or
that operate in the same sort of
headspace but when I listen to the show
I really feel like you get me I feel
like we think in the same sort of a way
so you know and the people are listening
might be I don't know what you're on
about Chris I just listen because you
got funny accent but if you know no
matter why it is that you you have the
opportunity to find someone that speaks
to you that might be Tim Ferriss that
might be the girls from pretty little
thing that might be Peter Crouch the
footballer you know whatever it is the
more that you align yourself with people
who have words that land with you rather
than words that just go past you I think
that's a good place to be yeah and what
happens when your environment is it's
not really motivating here is that you
have all those stereotypes and labels in
there because people just reinforce
what's familiar for them and if you
won't get out of those stereotypes of
behavior that they do define their
community by like it will be very very
hard for you to change your actions
because you will be criticized if you're
doing something else and I must I must
comment here is that you're you're
absolutely right that bad friends are
probably like worse than no friends you
know I'm very eclectic with my time and
I got it
I don't have a lot of friends and you
know Mayville has has commented on how
precious his time is once saying that he
doesn't do non-transactional meetings
meaning that you know if there is no
concrete value coming out of a meeting
or a coffe he's not going to meet a
person you know an email or a phone call
is enough and before even it escalates
the phone call he'll that very very well
whether this person is worth their time
and I think that once you've said a
certain value for your time saying that
and he actually said that at the
beginning of his career he was he was he
was constantly evaluating his time in
terms of even the smallest ant that he
had to do so if he had to do an Amazon
return for like ten dollars like it
wasn't worth like an hour of his time
because he could generate more money in
this hour okay so this is a very very
good kind of vetting of your time you
just need to again be very objective and
ask yourself do I really need to spend
my time on a and B and C and
unfortunately this could include some
friends that you know you can't really
you know talk about the things that
matter to you that could be business or
philosophy or something that kids
elevate your mind and you know can can
make you feel that this this meeting is
useful in in some way yeah it's the
crazy thing as well is to consider that
some people find that group of friends
straight away like that's mad to me the
fact that you know you just happen to
stumble by chance let's call it what it
is you know like you live in halls of
residence which is randomly assigned
next to some person that ends up being
your best mate for the rest of time
I feel very fortunate my business
partner i sat next to my business
partner of 13 years in my first ever
seminar like that's it just by chance
but this is amazing consciously as
you've hit the nail on the head there
having friends for the sake of having
friends if they don't bring you up and
perhaps even bring you down if you go
away from people feeling like your mind
is degree
you would genuinely be better off on
your own and I think this is one of the
few times where introverts have a
competitive advantage I've been talking
about this recently to do with kovat
they're usually in almost all situations
extroverts tend to have a competitive
advantage because they're easier to
socialize they can do put more time in
with people that means that they can
compound their networking effect more
quickly however there's a few particular
situations in which introverts end up
having a competitive advantage and one
of them is in being more frugal with
their time and not wasting it on people
that they don't value and the other one
is when they have to become their own
disciplinarians and work on their own by
their own and that's obviously happened
in Kove it as well yeah absolutely and I
see myself as a phenotypic extrovert so
why what's that it sounds that sounds
like a kind of mushroom so phenotype
it's a term in genetics that basically
is like how something is is seen
basically so in a cell it would be the
morphology the shape of the cell so this
is the Southfield phenotype so neurons
would have long axons this is the
neuronal phenotype okay so I call myself
a phenotypic extrovert because I'm very
comfortable with socializing and you
know like having a lot of friends but
actually I do enjoy my alone time and I
think that this also has to do with your
self-esteem so it all comes back with
being comfortable being with yourself
basically because what we see in a lot
of extroverts is they actually just they
cannot stand being alone you know and
they just need a company to fill this
void because they have nothing to offer
to themselves and they don't really know
how to cope with this and for this
reason I mean this is not always the
case obviously but you get what I'm
saying here and I think that this is
also an art to to be self-sufficient and
this is something that definitely
gives an intrapreneur an unfair
advantage whether they are an introvert
or an extrovert absolutely yeah I feel
for extroverts who are uncomfortable
having the amount of time on their own
that they need to do the introspective
work and reflection required to develop
themselves again you know to the
introverts out there that is your
competitive advantage the fact that
you're perfectly fine spending in a
whole day with just yourself is an
opportunity it's an opportunity to
reflect on you the way that you operate
to read a book and sit and just think
about it for 10 minutes while you make
yourself a cup of coffee or whatever it
might be because you in a different
version the extrovert version of you
would be ringing a friend while they
make the coffee that we FaceTime someone
while they make a coffee whereas to you
that feels to the introvert that feels
like absolute hell and you just want to
make your coffee in peace okay so use
that time you have the opportunity to
use this time and you know to start sort
of looping it back to what we said at
the beginning so you talked about the
fact that self-esteem is the foundation
that you need to believe that you are
worth more than you are you need to
relate your current outcomes to your
current actions what was next what came
after that
ah it's basically the ability to keep on
iterating and you know just keep on
going and trying different things
because this is how you will inevitably
succeed one day when you'll find the
perfect kind of product market fit this
is a term from Silicon Valley where you
know a product goes viral basically so
you just need to to try different things
to see what sticks best and this is how
it's done and to comment on what you
said previously is that sometimes we do
hear those success stories of
entrepreneurs and you know you have the
like people that knew them back from
high school or something saying yeah
he or she was just such a quiet child
and you know like we had no idea and
this overnight success it's like really
came out of nowhere no it wasn't
overnight
as it was the fact that this person was
comfortable just to be focused on their
goals yeah I think is whether the
iterating on your on project is an
important one because it brings us back
to seeing failures as a lesson not yeah
not as a comment on your self-worth
which again keeps your self-esteem your
confidence robust to the inevitable
challenge that you're going to come up
against so we've got that we've got the
fact you need to continue iterating
we've got the fact that you might need
to change your tribe and your social
circle in order to give you better
influence so that you start give
yourself room even it doesn't even
necessarily need to be and this is the
negative neutral positive of friendships
it doesn't even necessarily need to be
someone that brings you up just having
someone that doesn't bring you down yeah
is a great start you'd that person
that's always negative that's always
saying always comparing themselves
playing keeping up with the Jones is
terrible with money terrible with
keeping promises always late for their
meet you know someone that's late all
the time it's such a warning sign as a
friend you know because it literally
just says my time is worth more than
your time like what does that say about
the rest of your friendship yes of
course yeah so you know when you'll be
in a difficult situation you know how
will this friend behave and like will
they even help you you know so it's this
this matter of accountability and
trustworthiness got you so any final
pearls of wisdom or things that people
can take away from this anything that
you wouldn't want to leave people to
part with okay so there is a saying that
you probably have heard before and it's
just be yourself okay and I I what they
forget to add is that you need to be the
best version of yourself okay so you you
can't just be in your boring selves that
never gets out of your comfort zone and
then expecting everyone to like you and
then being angry that this advice didn't
work so instead of focusing on external
circumstances
my advice would be to always focus on
yourself and your self-improvement just
keep on honing those skills that will
inevitably give you the results that you
want
I love it Elena really really cool I
think there's an interesting discussion
to be had about what our true self is
anyway I mean I thought about this this
morning so if someone gets a nose job
plastic surgery on their nose is that
nose still their nose and you can kind
of see self development as an internal
version of that like well how much of
the things that I make my new self do my
new ways of seeing the world ways of
operating if I develop a new morning
routine and start meditating am I then
is meditation still me is that me as a
meditator how does it work and it is
it's an interesting sort of
philosophical question actually to ask
that and if anyone that's listening that
has an answer to that whether or not
having a nose job is still your nose and
then the same whether or not doing
behavior change makes you more of you or
less of you I'd love to find out the
answer to that so let me know la no
where can people go they want to find
out more about guild of growth I'll
check you out online why do they go yeah
sure so they go on the website it's
guild of growth calm and then we have a
Facebook in an Instagram pages guild of
growth I also enjoy micro blogging on
Twitter so they can find me by my name
so it's Elena Sara Nova Ysera Nova and
yeah this is it I would be happy to get
in touch oh I will link everything in
the show notes below guild of growth in
Elena's Twitter going gone hassle are on
there if you want to talk about self
developments and self esteem and stuff
like that I think that would be really
cool Elena it's really really great I
look forward to our hope that you see
the final year of your academics often
you can get this PhD knocked out as well
thank you thank you it's been an
absolute pleasure catch you later on
[Music]
you